there's no lockdown in brazil
despite soaring infection rates but the
favelas in sao paulo are quiet
people are scared of covid and brazil's
highly infectious p1 variant
they're so scared in fact where they can
they stay at home
[Music]
everyone knows somebody who has died or
is ill
like many others this intensive care
ward in sao paulo
is full the only three beds available
are where the previous occupant has died
or survived
it's usually the former the point is
icus across the country
are in the same state some say it's a
third wave
others argue the first wave just never
ended
a parliamentary inquiry into the
handling of the pandemic that's claimed
the lies of over five hundred thousand
people is underway
it has become absolute box office senate
tv
is now required viewing it streamed all
day
as witness after witness allege that the
government of right-wing president
jaya bolsonaro failed to buy vaccines
promoted
ineffective covet cures and neglected to
source adequate oxygen supplies
close allies like former soldier now
congressman general
eliezer zero insists that the whole
thing is a politically motivated attack
on the president nothing more
it's very difficult for us to to support
which which is the best way to to combat
coffee i don't know i think that you
don't know to
no country uh did this
and it's i support it it's okay united
states of america they have is six
thousand six hundred thousand we are
five thousand chile they use it to
to apply i think that coronavac
yeah and and they are still
losing people
would you support the vaccine here
yes president bolsonaro is a divisive
figure in brazil who plays entirely to
his base
at his last event he turned up at the
front of a motorbike rally
he resolutely denies the dangers of
covid fought against lockdowns and masks
and promoted drugs like
hydroxychloroquine
made famous by donald trump
he has kept up his public appearances
greeting
wildly supportive fans and ignoring
social distance
critics of the president including
supreme court judges like jamar mendes
warned the president about the virus but
he was obsessed
with the economy
[Music]
the hundreds of thousands of people who
have turned out across the country to
protest at bolsonaro's actions
and polls showing his popularity
plummeting ahead of an election next
year suggests he's in trouble
over half a million dead has shocked
brazil and this covet outbreak
is out of control mr ramsay sky news
brazilian